the conversation in buffalo over the
past few weeks has been
whether or not fans will be allowed to
attend playoff games
we were getting to the point where if it
was going to happen it needed to happen
soon because the first playoff game
to be hosted by the buffalo bills since
december 1996
is coming up on january 9 or january 10.
the announcement was made today
the bills will have 6 700 fans
at their first playoff game it's less
than 10 capacity they're concerned about
common areas they're concerned about
restrooms they're concerned about
keeping people apart
every fan will be tested before the game
you have to be negative there's going to
be contact tracing
after the game masks are required
physical distancing is required new york
is taking this seriously
but they found a way to let a select
few of the bills mafia attend the game
and
i have a feeling that those tickets are
going to go for a lot of money
but you're not getting in wouldn't that
be something you spend a lot of money
for the ticket but you don't get in
because you tested positive in whatever
window
the testing requirement will apply
and here is josh allen the bill's
quarterback who has taken to the bill's
mafia the way that they have taken to
him that relationship was even
solidified by the donations made during
the season when his grandmother patricia
allen died and
all of that money that flowed into
children's hospital
allen is already committed to being a
bill for life the fans love him here's
alan with his message
to the bills fan base goes matthew
what's up
i'm excited to let you guys know we are
going to be allowed some fans in our
first playoff game
super excited for it i want to thank all
the parties involved obviously the
pagulas governor cuomo
everybody else involved thank you so
much let's please follow guidelines wear
your masks in the sand so we can have
you guys for the rest of the way
go bills and
the 6700 fans isn't all that many but
it's still
6 700 fans it adds some energy and
excitement
to the stadium and it's dramatically
better
than no fans at all it was tj watt who
explained to me
this past weekend after the steelers
came back and beat the colts that they
have to constantly come up with their
own energy at heinz field that
giant vacant yellow seated
monstrosity that just looks bizarre with
no one there
6700 will be enough to generate some
energy and get some positivity and to
get some positivity into this show let's
bring in shereen williams hello shireen
the bills with 6 700 fans i think a lot
more dangerous than the bills at home
with no fans
yeah and they've lost one home game this
year mike and that was to kansas city
and they're not obviously not going to
play kansas city at home
in the playoffs but they hope that they
end up going to kansas city
to the championship game and to do that
they'll get a couple
couple of home games they hope they get
that number two seed and
get to host whoever comes to them for
the divisional round so
it's big though it's going to be cold we
we know that
and now there's going to be some noise
in there too mike that's a really tough
place to play anyway
but having just 6 700 fans i think is
going to make it even tougher for
whoever has to go in there in whatever
rounds
the bill's keeping the cards close to
the vest on whether or not they're going
to play starters this weekend when a win
would nail down the number two seed a
loss by the steelers would give the
bills the number two seed as well
but there's no guarantee the steelers
are going to lose even with mason
rudolph at quarterback because of the
ongoing
covet issues with the cleveland browns
we'll be talking about that coming up
for now though
the bills i continue to believe the most
dangerous team currently in the nfl it
could change
and that's one of the reasons why i
think they should go all out this
weekend
continue to build momentum continue to
show
everyone else but more importantly
yourself that you're a dominant team and
you are going into the playoffs on a
high note and you are ready
to beat anyone you know i think that
they are no longer content to just
get to the playoffs this is the year
they try to take it next level
having those fans there shireen will
help the big challenge is
can they get back to their fifth super
bowl now it would be helpful number one
if they could avoid the ravens in the
wild card round which i'm sure they're
very cognizant in that possibility
number two if someone else would take
care of the chiefs for them
so the bills would have an easier path
to the super bowl but i don't think they
want easy i think they want to take on
anyone and everyone to show that they've
arrived and i believe as of now they
have things can change but as of right
now
if they would play anyone tonight i
think the bills would beat them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports